huit ans de présence crée une
instabilité toujours grandissante de
plus en plus critiqué l'opération
militaire française au sahel n'a
semble-t-il pas vocation à prendre fin
dans un futur proche mais des
ajustements pourraient avoir lieu
concède la ministre des armées florence
parly qui continue de militer pour une
solution politique
dire que la france est englué dans une
guerre sans fin est faux notre présence
n'est certainement pas éternel les
progrès politiques dont dépend la
résolution définitive de la crise sont
loin d'être allé au même rythme que les
avancées militaires
il n'y a pas de solution militaire sans
solution politique
nous ne voulons pas que le sahel
devienne une sorte d'académie du
terrorisme parfois remise en cause au
sein même des pays concernés
l'intervention française devrait donc se
poursuivre et ce malgré un bilan mitigé
à l'image de la dernière année écoulée
si la france peut se targuer d'avoir
neutraliser plusieurs cadres djihadistes
comme le chef d'al qaïda au maghreb
islamique en juin dernier
elle constate dans le même temps de
lourdes pertes civiles en 2020 ils sont
plus de 2000 à avoir perdu la vie dans
les zones où le conflit fait rage depuis
plusieurs semaines l'armée française se
retrouve également sous le coup d'une
suspicion de bavures une frappe aérienne
qui visait un groupe terroriste aurait
été à l'origine de victimes civiles
selon des villageois malien paris nie
toute responsabilité mais le doute
subsiste
pas de quoi arranger l'image déjà
écornée de l'opération barkan